Joe Biden actually could lose the first
two 2024 presidential contests and it's
for a whole sort of fakakta reason about
how Biden wanted the the primary
contests to begin in South Carolina
because one it's easier to control South
Carolina in terms of the Democratic
Party Machine but uh two he thinks he's
going to do better there than in say
Iowa and New Hampshire the party hasn't
totally gone along with that Iowa New
Hampshire are not happy about that so if
Iowa New Hampshire continue to be the
first States Biden could lose if he
doesn't really campaign there if he
doesn't appear on the ballot there and
if RFK Jr does campaign there RFK Jr who
is doing a lot better than than many
people who would challenge an incumbent
president RFK junior is polling
somewhere between 15 and 20 percent
right now and RFK could win New
Hampshire could win Iowa and it still
won't matter but it will be pretty
embarrassing for Joe Biden